First question we want her discuss
has to do with the possibility of my
surviving my death.
Is there life after death?
Is there a possibility that I might
still exist or survive after my death?
Now at first glance,
and in fact I think at second glance
is going to turn out to be true.
You might think that the answer to
this question would depend on two basic
issues. You know, do I survive my
death? Do we survive our deaths?
You think first thing we'd have to
get clear on is, well, what am I,
what kind of a thing am I?
Or generalizing what kind of a thing
is a person? What are we made of?
What are our parts?
It seems plausible to think that
before we can answer the question,
you know, do I survive? We
need to know how I'm built.
And so the first thing we're going to
spend a fair bit of time on is trying to
get clear on what's up person.
What are the fundamental fundamental
building blocks of a person?
Second question that you might think
we'd want to get clear on is what's the
idea or what's the concept of surviving?
So we need to get it task, you know,
do I survive?
We need to get clear on what
am I and what is it to survive?
What is it for something that
exists in the future to be me.
Now this question can be discussed
philosophically and quite general terms.
What's the nature of persistence
of identity over time?
But since we're especially
interested in beans like us people,
uh,
this topic is sort of sub specialized
version of the question of identity gets
discussed under the rubric of the topic,
personal identity.
What's the key or the nature or the basis
of personal identity as we might put
it?
What is it for somebody who's here
next week to be the same person as me?
What's the nature of personal
identity? So as I say, at first glance,
you might think, well, to
get clear on the answer,
do I or might I or could
I survive my death?
We need to know what am I,
what's a person?
What's the metaphysical composition
of people on the one hand?
And we need to get clear on the nature
of identity or persistence or more
specifically personal
identity. Now, as I say,
I believe that when push comes to shove,
we do need to get clear about
both of those questions.
And so that's going to take the
first several weeks of the class.
We're going to spend a couple of weeks
talking about what's a person and then
we're going to spend several weeks,
or at least a week or so talking
about the nature of personal identity.
But before we can even get started,
there's a question,
really an objection to the
whole enterprise. You know,
so we're about to spend a lot of time
asking the philosophical question,
is there life after death? Could
there be life after death? Uh,
might I survive my death?
But there's a philosophical
objection to the entire question.
And the objection is fairly simple.
It says,
the whole question is misconceived.
It's,
it's based on a confusion.
Once we see the confusion,
we can see what the
answer to our question as,
could I survive my death?
The answer has got to be,
this is what the objection
says. The answer's got to
be, obviously not. All right.
So here,
here's the objection and I should
mention that the very first reading that
you're going to be doing a as a
couple of pages from Jay Rosenberg,
a contemporary philosopher,
and he gives us a version
of this objection.
So I'll give you one version. You'll have
another version in your readings. The,
the, the objection basically says, look,
what does it mean to say that somebody
died? You know, we're asking, you know,
is there life after death? What does it
mean to say that somebody has died? Well,
a natural,
uh,
definition of death might be
something like the end of life.
All right, so then if
that's right, then to ask,
is there life after death is just asking,
is there life after the end of life?
And the answer to that ought
to be pretty obvious. Well,
obviously the answer to that is
no. After all, if we're saying,
once you've run out of life,
is there any more life?
Well, Duh, the answer that's, that's,
that's like asking when I've eaten up
all the food on my plate or is there any
food left on my plate or what happens
in the movie after the movie ends?
These are stupid questions because once
you understand what they're asking,
the answer is just built in.
It follows trivially.
So although it has seemed to people over
the ages that the question is there,
life after death is one
of the great mysteries.
One of the great philosophical things to
ponder the objection says that's a kind
of illusion. In fact, once you think
about it and not all that long,
you can see the answer's got to be no,
there couldn't possibly
be life after death.
There couldn't possibly be
like after the end of life.
Or suppose we ask the question
in a slightly different way,
might I survive my death?
Well,
what does the word survive
mean? Well, you know, survive.
It's something like we say
that somebody who's a survivor,
if something's happening,
they haven't, uh, they haven't
died. They're still alive.
Uh, you know, when there's a
car accident, you ask, you know,
so and so died so and so's
survived. Uh, you know,
this person survived to
say that they survived.
It's just saying that they're still alive.
So might I survive my death?
Is like asking,
might I still be alive
after? Well, what's death?
Death is the end of life.
So might I still be alive
after I've stopped living?
Uh, might I be one of the people
who didn't die when I died? Oh Gosh.
The answer that is, again, Duh. No,
you couldn't possibly survive your death
given the very diff that this should
remind us of a,
I don't know.
At least it reminds me of this joke that
you probably told it seemed hysterical
when you were were seven, right? The, um,
plane crashes a exactly on the border
of Canada and the United States.
Exactly. On the border. And there
there's dead people everywhere.
Where do they bury the survivors?
And the answer is, well,
you don't bury the survivors, you know,
so when you're 70 you think, I don't know,
do they buried them in Canada and they
buried America, right? The answer,
you don't bury the survivors because
survivors or people that haven't yet died.
So can I survive my death is like
asking could I not have yet died after?
And the answer is no.
Of course you have to have died if you
died and you haven't survived if you've
died. Right? So the question
can't even get off the ground.
That at least is how the objection goes.
Now I don't mean to be utterly
dismissive of the objection.
That's why I spent a couple of
minutes trying to spell it out,
but I think there's a
way to respond to it.
We just have to get clear
about what precisely the
question is that we're trying
to ask. And it says something
that Rosenberg tries to
get clear on it as well.
So here's my attempt to make the question
both a bit more precise and a question
that's an open question,
a question we can legitimately raised.
Well now, as you'll hear on several
occasions over the course of the semester,
I'm a philosopher. What that means is I
don't really know a whole lot of facts.
Uh, and so I'm about to tell you a
story where I wish I knew the facts. Uh,
and I don't know the facts. If it was, you
know, if, if I could really do it right,
I know open the door and bring in,
uh,
our guests physiologist who would then
provide the facts that I am what I'm
about to go blue, you your
new job. But you know, we,
we'd have the physiologists come in and
pretend and he'd actually tell us these
things. I don't know. I don't know
them. I don't have that person.
But take a look at what
happens when a body dies. Uh,
now, no doubt you can kill
people and a lot of different
ways you can, you can, uh,
poison them. You can strangle them,
you can shoot them in the heart.
Um,
the,
the causal paths that result
in death may start differently.
But,
but I presume that they converge
and you end up having a set,
a set of events take place. Now
what are those events? This is,
this is exactly where, I don't really
know what the details, but I take it,
it's something like, because of
whatever the original input was,
eventually the bloods no
longer circulating and
oxygen isn't making its way
around the body.
And so the brain becomes oxygen starved
because of the lack of oxygen getting to
the cells.
The cells are no longer able to carry
on their various metabolic processes
because of this.
They can't repair the various kinds of
damage they need or create the amino
acids and proteins they need.
And so as decay begins to set in and
the cell structures begin to break down,
uh, they don't get repaired
as they would normally do.
And so eventually we have breakdown of
the crucial cell structures and boom,
the body's dead. Now just say, I don't
really know whether that's accurate,
the little rough story I just told about
some story. Like that's probably right.
And in typical philosophical fashion,
I've drawn that story for you
up here on the board, right?
So the events that I don't
really know the details of,
we can just call B one B
two B three up through B n.
So you know before be one begins,
you got, you know, the body working,
functioning and it's bodily
way respirating reproducing
this sells and so forth
and so on. And at the end of
the, of the process by Ben,
the body's dead.
So you know,
be for bodily B one through Ben.
That's what death is,
death of the body is. And as I say,
it's the sort of thing that uh,
somebody from the medical school or a
biologist or a physiologist or something
could, could describe for us.
So here's the question then.
Suppose we call that
process death of the body.
Okay.
Call what has occurred by the
end of that sequence of events,
bodily death.
Okay.
Now here's a question
that we can still ask.
At least it looks as
though we can still ask it.
Might I or do I still exist
after the death of my body?
Might I still exist
after bodily death now?
I don't mean to suggest in any way that
we yet know the answer to that question,
but at least that's a question that it
seems as though we can coherently raise,
there is no obvious
contradiction in asking,
might I still exist after
the death of my body
dancer club turn out to be no,
but at least it's not.
Obviously no.
If the answer turns out to be no,
it's going to take some,
some sustained argument to
settle it one way or the other.
The answer could turn out to be yes for
all we know at point they sort of just
brings us back to the thought that well,
whether or not I could still exist
after the death of my body looks like it
should depend on what I am and so in a
minute that's the question that I'm going
to turn to, but it's a bit
cumbersome to constantly be asking,
you know,
might I still exist after the death
of my body and so no harm is done.
Once we've clarified the question
that we're trying to ask,
if we summarize that question
in a bit of a jargon or slogan,
we say instead of asking might I survive
and why they continue to exist after
the death of my body, we might
ask, we might put it this way.
We might say for short,
will I survive the death of my body,
no harm done or will I survive my death?
Because what we were just stipulating,
we mean when we talk about my death in
the context of this question is the death
of my body no harm done. We can
just say for short, you know,
will I survive my death or might I
survive my death or for that matter,
no serious harm. John, if we ask,
is there life after death?
As long as we understand that we're not
asking about there is life of my body
just to know they're familiar way of
trying to ask will I still be around after
my death?
Will I still exist after my death?
So I think there's a perfectly legitimate
question and that's the question we
now want to turn to now.
As I said,
it looks as though to answer the question,
you know,
could I continue to exist after the death
of my body? Is there life after death?
Could I survive my death for short?
To answer that question,
we need to get clearer about, well, what
exactly is it for something to be me?
That's a question we'll turn
to in a couple of weeks.
First we've got to get clear
about, well, what am I,
what kind of an entity am I?
What am I made of in philosophical jargon?
This is a question from metaphysics,
so we'll ask him the
metaphysical question.
What kind of a thing is a person does?
It seems plausible to think that whether
or not a person can survive or continue
to exist after the death of his or her
body should depend on how he's built,
what he's made of,
what his or her parts are.
So let me sketch for you to
basic positions on this question.
What is a person to basic positions?
They're both,
I imagine,
fairly familiar and what we're going
to have to do is try to decide between
them.
They're not the only possible positions
on the question of the metaphysics of
the person. But there I think
the two most prominent positions,
definitely the ones with both, most
worth taking seriously for our purposes.
So first possible position is this.
A person is a combination of
a body and something else,
a mind.
But the crucial thing about this first
year that we wanted to talk about is that
the mind is thought of as something
separate from and distinct from the body.
So it's, well, to use a common
enough word, it's a soul.
So people are,
or people have or people
consist of bodies and souls.
The soul is something, as I
say, distinct from the body.
I take it the idea of the
body's a familiar one. It's,
it's this lump of flesh and
bone and muscle, you know, that,
that that's sitting here in front of you.
And then each one of use or drags around
with you, that sort of thing that,
you know, we can put on a scale and
pride with, you know, with a stick. Uh,
and the biologists can study,
presumably made up of various kinds of
molecules. Atoms and so forth. All right,
so we've got the body,
but on this first view,
we also have something that's not body,
something that's not a material object,
something that's not composed of
molecules and atoms. It's a soul.
It's the the house of or
the seed of or the basis of,
of consciousness and
thinking perhaps personality.
But the crucial point for this view
is that the proper metaphysical
understanding of the mind is to
think of it and nonphysical terms,
nonmaterial terms. That is, I say,
is the first basic view. I'm going
to say something more about that.
If you have a fair bit more about that
view over over the next couple of weeks.
But first, let me sketch the
other basic view. So, so,
so this first view we can call
the dualist view dual list.
Of course,
because there's two basic components,
the body and the soul,
and although I may occasionally slip,
I'm going to try to
preserve the word soul.
When I used the word soul,
I'm going to have in mind this dualist
view according to which the soul is
something immaterial,
nonphysical, some other kind,
you know the body's a material substance.
The soul is an immaterial substance.
It's the dualist view.
The alternative view that we're going
to consider is not dualist button,
but Moonest.
It says there's one basic kind of
thing and only one basic kind of thing.
There are bodies,
so what's a person?
A person is just a surgeon
kind of material object.
A person is just a body.
Of course,
it's a very fancy material object.
It's a very amazing material object.
That's what this second view says.
The person is a body that can do things
that most other material objects can't
do.
So on the Mona's view,
which we'll call physicalism because
it says that what people just are these
physical objects on
the physical list view,
a person is just a body that
can now you fill in the blank.
All right? You, you point out the kinds of
things that we can do. Well, we can talk,
we can think, we can sing, we can
write poetry. We can fall in love.
We can be afraid. Uh, we can make plans,
we can discover things about the universe.
Well,
according to the physical list view,
a person is just a body that can do
all of those things, can reflect,
can be rational, can communicate,
can make plans, can fall in love,
can write poetry. That's the
physicalist you. So as I say,
we've got two basic positions.
There's the dualist view people,
our bodies and souls.
And there there's the physicalist view
according to which there are no souls.
There are no in material
objects like that.
There are only bodies though when you got,
you know,
a functioning body like ours.
So there's physical says these bodies
can do some pretty amazing things.
The kinds of things that we all
know, people can do. Two basic views.
Now from a logical point of
view, I suppose you might
have a third possible view.
You know, if we've got the Moaners
who says, oh yeah, there's bodies,
but there's no souls. You could imagine
somebody who says there are souls,
but there are no bodies.
Uh,
this would roughly be a view
according to which there are mines,
but there aren't really physical objects.
Physical objects are kind of allusion
perhaps that we fall into or thinking
about them in materialistic terms might
be greatly, uh, confused or mistaken.
This view is sometimes known in
philosophy as idealism. You know,
all that exists,
our minds and their ideas.
Physical objects is just a way of
talking about the ideas the mind has or
something like that.
Idealism is a position that's got a
very long history and philosophy and you
know, for many classes would
be worth taking, you know,
a fair bit of time to
consider more carefully.
But for our purposes I
think it's not a contender.
So I'm just gonna put it aside.
The positions that I'm going to end our
other possibilities as well. You know,
there,
there are views where mind and body are
just two different ways of looking at
same underlying reality where the
underlying reality is neither physical nor
mental. That view is also worth
taking seriously metaphysics class.
Uh, but for our purposes I
mentioned it, put it aside,
the two views we're going to
focus on are on the one hand,
the dualist view,
people have souls as well as bodies
and the physical list view all we have,
all we are our bodies.
Yeah.
Well let me say something more than
about the dualist position coordinator to
dual list. The mind is this
immaterial substance and we could,
if we could call it by different
names, we could, no harm will be done.
If we call it a mind though.
The reason I will typically talk about
a soul is to try to flag the, the,
the crucial point that on the
dualist view, the mind is based in,
or he just is something nonphysical,
something non material.
We could call it a mind. We could call
it a soul. We can call it a psyche.
They say, I'll typically try
to call it, uh, the soul.
The soul can direct and give
orders to the body on the one hand.
And on the other hand,
the body sort of
generates input that eventually
gets sensed or felt by the soul.
Yet.
Yet you take a pen and Ja stick it through
my flesh of my body and I feel pain
in my soul,
in my mind.
So two way interaction. And as
always in with philosophy, there's,
there's more complicated
versions of dualism, uh,
where maybe the interaction
doesn't work both ways,
but let's just limit ourselves
to a good old fashion.
Two way interaction. [inaudible]
dualism. All right, so my,
my mind controls my body.
My body can affect my mind in
various ways. But for all of that,
they're separate things.
Still.
There's this very tight connection
and we sometimes put it the
soul is in the body though,
of course, talking about
spatial location here, maybe,
maybe somewhat
metaphorically a an intended,
it's not as though we think that
if you start opening up the body,
you'd finally find the particular spot.
Okay,
here's the place where
the soul is located.
So it does seem from this duelist
perspective is all souls are located.
I'm sort of viewing the world from here,
just like each of you is viewing the
world from a particular location.
So maybe your soul is located more
or less in the vicinity of your body.
Crucial point. Of course, the
attraction of the dualist view from,
from our point of view is that if there's
a soul as well as the body and the
soul is something in material,
then when the body dies,
when we have B one through Ben and the
death of the body occurs, you know,
so at the end of BN near the
body stops repairing itself.
Decay sets in. You know, we
all know the sad stories,
the worm crawling and the worms crawl out.
The end of the day we'll make
it takes longer than a day.
Know the body has decomposed.
Yes,
all that bespeaks the end of the body.
But if the soul is something immaterial,
then that could continue to exist even
after the destruction of the body.
That's, that's the, that's the attraction.
At least one of the attractions
of the dualist view.
The belief in the soul gives you something
to continue to exist after the end of
your body. You know?
So what's death? Well,
if normally there's this super tight
connection between my soul and my body,
death might be the severing of that
connection and so the body breaks and no
longer is able to give
input up to the soul.
The soul longer is no longer able to
control the body and make it move around,
but for all that the soul might
continue to exist and so at least the
possibility that I'll survive my
death is one worth taking very,
very seriously.
If we are dualists.
Couple of things to point
out about this view.
One is I've been talking as
though a person is a combination,
kind of are a soul and body sandwich,
so a person has two basic building blocks,
the bodily part and the sole part.
It's natural to talk that way,
but if we want belief in the soul to
help us hold out the possibility at least
that there might be life after death,
then I think we need to actually
say that strictly speaking,
it's not that a person
is a soul plus a body.
Strictly speaking,
I think we need to say the
person just is the soul.
After all.
If the person is the combination,
if the person is the pear sole,
plus the body destroys the body,
you've destroyed the pair.
If the person the pair and
the pair no longer exists,
the person no longer exists.
So if we want belief in
a soul to help us leave,
open the door to the possibility that
I survive the destruction of my body,
it better not be that the
bodies and essential part of me,
it's simpler,
more straight forward to
say instead what I am,
strictly speaking is a soul.
As long as the soul exists,
I exist.
Of course my soul,
me,
I have a very tight connection
to a particular body.
But still you could in
principle destroying the body
with d without destroying
me. Look, I have a particularly close
connection to the house I live in,
but for all that,
you can destroy my house
without destroying me.
So that's I think the position that
we ought to ascribe to the dualist.
The person is strictly speaking the soul.
The soul has a very intimate
connection with the body,
but the person is not the soul and
the body. The person is just the soul.
So even have that intimate connection
gets destroyed. The person,
the soul could continue to exist.
Second point to clear,
clear up is that there's really three
different issues that might interest us.
One,
metaphysically our bodies and souls
distinct is there is the mind to be
understood in terms of
this in material object,
the soul, so are there two kinds of
things? That's the first question.
Our souls and bodies distinct.
Second question though is does the soul,
even if it exists,
does the soul survive the
destruction of the body?
It could be something
separate without surviving.
That's why I've tried to
say if there are souls,
at least that opens the door to the
possibility that we will survive our debt
but doesn't guarantee it because
absent further argumentation,
who is no guarantee that the soul
survives the death of the body,
even if it's separate,
it could be that it gets killed at the
very same time or destroyed at the very
same time the body's being destroyed.
Maybe when you know
these physical processes,
B one through B n take place,
they set into motion. Remember after
all, we're interaction as dualists.
There's this very tight causal connection
between the body and the mind and the
soul and the body,
the body and the soul.
Just like when you prick my body,
that bodily process sets up certain
things taking place in my soul.
Maybe when B one through Ben take place,
they set up some other
processes in my soul.
Call them s one through s n and maybe
s one through s n results in the
destruction of my soul.
So simultaneously with my body dying,
my soul dies.
Okay.
This one's going to be a little bit
trickier to draw this. So the first part,
your s one. Dot. Dot, dot,
dot. Dot. That's easy. S.
N the question is how do I draw
the soul? I don't really know. Uh,
yeah.
So the mere fact that we decide if we do
ultimately decide that there is a soul,
something nonphysical,
separate and distinct from the body,
doesn't guarantee that we
survive our physical death.
That's going to be a separate question.
We'll have to turn to first question's
going to be, are there any Sol's?
Next question is going to
have to be if there are,
do we have any good reason to think
that they survive the death of the body?
Third question that might interest us,
it does interest us is this,
if it survives,
how long does it survive?
Does the soul continue to exist
after the death of the body?
Does it continue to exist forever?
Yeah.
Are we immortal?
Most of us would like that to be true.
We want there to be souls so that we can
be a mortal and so the question's got
to be not only is the sole distinct,
does it survive the death of my body,
but does it continue to exist forever?
Okay.
Those questions,
hang on one sec.
Those questions are ones that
especially interest Plato,
so in about a week or so,
we'll start reading Plato's Fito.
The purpose of that dialogue of that
philosophical work is to argue for the
immortality of the soul. So that's a
question we'll be turning to. Yeah,
that's the
question that you are going to
consider a different version.
Like the nature of the soul inosine
material. We know that for sure.
But then the very word material means
that not going to be by and material
position process such as the body.
Okay, so, so the question is this.
So if the very idea of soul that we're
working with here under the doulas
picture is the soul is an immaterial
substance. It's not made of ordinary,
you know, atomic matter.
If the soul is in material,
doesn't it follow automatically trivially
that this soul cannot be destroyed by
material process after all
there was death in the body,
B one through B and that's a
material process, a physical process.
Doesn't it follow that?
A soul,
an immaterial entity can't be destroyed
by a material physical process.
What I want to say,
it's great question.
What I want to say is sort of the short
answer for now is I don't think it
follows automatically.
It doesn't follow trivially.
It may follow.
Plato's actually going to give us some
arguments for pretty much that same clean
plane is going to argue once we understand
the sort of metaphysical nature of
the soul.
We'll see why it couldn't be destroyed.
That's going to take some fancy arguments.
The reason I think it doesn't
follow trivially is because,
remember I said we're in dealing
with interactions, just dualism.
We've already admitted that bodies
are able to affect the soul,
right? You know, the,
the body is having all sorts of light
bounce off my eyes of various wavelengths
and because of that,
my soul is having various
visual sensations about the
number of people in front
of me,
colors and so forth and so on.
I gave the example of pricking my body.
That's a physical process that causes
some sorts of changes in the mental
processes occurring in my soul.
Okay.
Once we've admitted that on this kind
of dual is picture the material body can
influence what happens
in the immaterial soul,
then it doesn't seem that we have any
grounds for shutting the door to the
possibility that the
right physical process,
B one through Ben might set up
this horrible mental soul process,
s one through s and resulting
in the destruction of the
soul. It's a possibility.
It's going to take more
arguments to rule it out. Yeah.
My soul is somewhere.
Is that reasonable when
you're talking about,
yeah, so that was another great
question. The question was,
I said seems plausible in the same as
soul is locate soul is located more or
less here, cause I sent him seem
to view the world from here,
but maybe that's not right.
Maybe we shouldn't talk about
the location of the soul at all.
After all,
if the soul is an in material object,
can in material objects have locations,
I don't know. I mean the short
answer is I don't know. Uh,
I know very little about how in
material objects are supposed to work.
So although I'm trying to
sketch the dualist position,
as I explained on Tuesday,
I don't myself believe in souls.
I don't actually think that
the dual list view is correct.
Mike say I'll leave that problem our souls
spatially located or not to be worked
out by those who believe in it.
For our purposes,
I think it doesn't really matter if
you want to say souls have location,
where are they located located more or
less where my body is at least as long as
my body's working.
Maybe at death,
the soul gets liberated from the body
and is able to wander more freely.
Sometimes people talk about, in fact,
we'll be reading about this, you know,
out of body experiences. Uh, and so
maybe during those unusual times, the,
the sole wanders from the body and
comes back to it. Or alternatively,
maybe the soul doesn't
have any location at all.
Maybe that's just an illusion created
by the fact that I'm getting this visual
input from my body.
My body certainly has a location,
maybe, maybe the right way to, you know,
imagine somebody who was in a room with,
you know, remote controlled television
set up and so forth and so on. And,
and he's seeing what's
happening in Chicago,
even though he's sitting in
a room in new haven. Well,
you could understand why he might fall
into the trap of thinking of himself as
located in Chicago, if all the
visual inputs coming from Chicago.
So maybe that's how it
works with the soul.
We get lulled into thinking that
we are where our bodies are,
but that's really a metaphysical illusion.
Don't really know for our purposes.
I think it's not crucial
because it's a great question,
but I'm not going to try to
pursue it any further. All right,
so one question,
is there a sole second question,
does it survive the death of our
body? Third question, if it does,
does it live forever? Does it continue
to exist forever? Is the sole immortal?
We will initially think
about the first question,
do we have any good reason to believe
in souls at all and only after a while
where we turn to the second and
third question, does it survive?
And more particularly,
is it a mortal? Alright,
that's the first basic view
about the nature of a person.
Person is a soul,
something immaterial and not a body.
I take it at the views of familiar one.
Many of you probably believe in it.
Those of you who don't believe in it
had probably at least been tempted to
believe in it. I'm sure you all
do know people who believe in it.
It's a very familiar picture,
but of course the question we're going
to have to ask ourselves is, is it right?
Is the reasons to believe it's correct.
Let's turn now to the second basic view.
The view,
the physical list view according
to which a person is just a body.
This is a materialist view.
People are just material objects,
the sorts of things biologists
poke and prod and study.
Now it's important.
I think this is the crucial point that
when we say a person is just a body,
we don't understand that.
To me the physical is doesn't mean
that as a person is just any old body.
It's not as though there aren't important
differences between different physical
objects.
Some physical objects can do things have
a far more interesting sort than other
physical objects.
Here's a piece of chalk.
It's a physical object. It's
just a body. What can it do?
Well, not a whole lot. I can
write on the board with it.
I can break it into, you know,
you let go of, it drops down.
Not a very interesting physical body.
Here's a cell phone.
It's just a body.
It's not the most interesting
physical object in the world,
but it's a whole lot more
interesting than a piece of chalk.
It can do all sorts of things
a piece of chalk can't do.
If the physicalist is right,
then here's another
physical object for you.
Me,
Shelly Kagan,
I am a pretty impressive physical object.
Now arrogant is,
I may be,
I don't mean to suggest on any
more impressive than you guys are.
Each one of us,
according to the physical list,
is just a body that can
do some amazing things.
We are bodies that can think we,
our bodies that can plan.
We are bodies that can reason.
We our bodies that can feel,
we are bodies that can be afraid
and be creative and have dreams and
aspirations. We our bodies that
can communicate with each other.
We are bodies that are,
or here's a word for it.
We're bodies that are people,
but on the physicalist view,
a person is just a body and that's
where we'll take it up next time.